voulait déjà vous dire que cette saison
c'est vrai chaque saison est différente
chaque saison on croît chaque fois avoir
connu des choses qu'on connaîtra jamais
la saison d'après et chaque saison on
connaît des choses encore plus
formidable dans tous les sens et plus
étonnantes
extra cette saison on a commencé à faire
une saison on s'amusait beaucoup dans tp
c'est vraiment une saison où il ya une
excellente ambiance je vous le dis
vraiment il ya eu très très peu de
heurts entre les chroniqueurs il ya eu
on s'amuse et on était vraiment dans le
dans la rigolade cette année vraiment
vous voulez vraiment être dans la
rigolade et c'est ce qu'on fera encore
plus l'année prochaine puisque je vous
dis tu es pmp sera vraiment un espace de
divertissement à l'année prochaine c'est
vraiment un espace de divertissement va
vraiment que rigoler et balances ton
poste qui revient bien entendu ce sera
l'espace du débat
voilà c'est terminé il n'aura plus de
gros débats voilà deux sociétés dont et
pépé ça sera vraiment voilà je vous le
dis le divertissement la rigolade les
images les médias parce que ce qu'on
fait danser que du typhon on voit que ça
marche très bien
voilà revenir sur tout ce qui s'est
passé à la télé et bien entendu vous le
savez tous ceux qui veulent revenir sont
les bienvenus bien entendu de l'année
prochaine puisque vous êtes tous conviés
à participer à l'émission
on va revenir aussi je vous le dis un
plateau jeu comptera sur ce plateau
génial et on va revenir un plateau dans
la même configuration que celle qu'on
avait à l'époque
voilà le lors des premières avec un
public beaucoup plus rapprochées et un
plateau plus petit puisque c'est vrai
qu'on a besoin de s'entendre
c'est une émission de vannes et plomb
d'un plateau grand plus c'est compliqué
voilà donc c'est vrai que cette saison
elle a été elle était très bizarre et
c'est vrai que ces deux mois qu'on a
passé un mois et demi qu'on a passé
à faire à la maison on était un petit
peu loin les uns des autres est loin de
vous également le public parce que c'est
vrai qu'on avait l'impression de wilde
est loin de vous même si j'étais avec
vous tous les soirs à l'antenne
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas voulu vous
lâcher avec la chaîne avec s'est vite
est vraiment qu'on voulait vous
accompagner pendant ces moments qui ont
été difficiles on savait pas trop où on
allait et je voulais remercier public
qui a toujours été là vraiment tous les
gens qui m'ont soutenue sur twitter sur
un star sur facebook tous les gens qui
m'ont remercié d'avoir et à l'antenne
avec l'équipe pendant ces périodes de
confinement sachez qu'on l'a fait parce
que vous nous avez jamais lâché on a eu
des moments on est passé par tous les
moments ça fait maintenant on va faire
entamé la onzième saison la saison
prochaine et vous avez toujours été là
vous nous avez jamais lâché vous avez
été là sur tous mes projets je le vois
encore sur les boîtes lasser vous êtes
très très très nombreux tous les soirs
et de plus en plus nombreux à être à mes
côtés vous m'avez jamais lâché vous avez
toujours été là vous n'avez jamais cru
les bêtises qu'on a pu dire dans la
presse les attaques les jalousies qui a
pu avoir et je voudrais vous remercier
de votre fidélité vraiment d'être
d'avoir toujours été là pour moi et
sachez que nous on vous lâchera jamais
et ce qu'on fait bien entendu je vous le
dis voilà bien entendu c'est notre
métier on est là on on est on est
content d'être là où gagne bien notre
vie on est heureux mais on le fait est
vraiment je vous le dis on fait enfin je
pense pour la plupart à 90% pour vous
parce que c'est vous qui nous donner la
force de venir tous les jours c'est vous
qui nous donner la force vraiment d'être
d'avoir envie de vous montrer ce qu on a
fait tous les jours c'est un petit peu
voilà on ait envie de vous montrer ce
qu'on a envie de faire de vous montrer
des nouveaux projets de vous proposer
des nouvelles choses
on a envie de me divertir tous les soirs
et sue plus que jamais maintenant parce
que c'est vrai qu'on a connu des moments
assez compliqué et l'année prochaine ce
sera vraiment l'année du divertissement
il joue dur à la grosse rigolade
il y aura à prendre ou à laisser laura
tpm paix et il y aura btp qui sera
vraiment l'espace de débat mais dans tp
on va vraiment être dans la rigolade
absolue je sais que tous vous êtes
traitement d'un massif projet voilà ce
qui vous va très bien médias et dar k
voilà et je voudrais donc voila vous
dire merci je voudrais aussi dire merci
à la chaîne assez vite et tous les
techniciens vraiment qu'ils ont fait un
travail exceptionnel pendant le
confinement souli
c'est grâce à eux qu'on a pu être à
l'antenne je voudrais les remercier
avant tout les gars qui ont l'art des
verts bravo à vous savez que vous aime
beaucoup et je défendrai toujours vos
intérêts je voulais toujours dit et
j'essaie vraiment voilà de faire le max
pour vous vraiment je le ferai toujours
sachez le si vous avez n'importe quel
problème je sais que vous essayez de me
joindre vous essayer de m'en parler
et j'essaie de faire le maximum à chaque
fois je vous remercie également bien sûr
mon mokhtar voilà que je vois là parce
que mokhtar car d'amour et je vous
remercie également les patrons bien sûr
du groupe canal de ses huit qui nous ont
aussi eu jamais lâché et qui nous
suivent dans tous nos délires je peux
vous dire une liberté comme ça pour la
trouvera nulle part ailleurs
j'ai eu cette idée voilà de fer à
prendre ou à laisser
c'était deux semaines avant avant qu'on
sorte du confinement je leur ai dit
voilà j'ai envie de faire les boîtes je
sens que c'est le moment peut-être de
faire de remettre les boîtes à l'antenne
sur c'est vite vu le contexte
franchement voilà que ce soit maxime
saada gérald brice viret franck appietto
vincent pujol alexandre israël voilà
tous les décideurs voilà où dit tout de
suite oui on y va c'est incroyable
d'avoir une telle liberté dans une
chaîne et on a tout mis en place pour
deux semaines et surtout j'aimerais
remercier bien entendu mon lionel stan
mon directeur général d'aj de dos qui a
tout mis en place en quelques jours lui
et c'est ça que j'aime chez lui tout est
possible
il est toujours partant et vous dis
toujours oui c'est possible
voilà donc voila et bien sûr tous ceux
qui sont avec moi h2o a bien sûr loïc
voilà qui a fait un travail également
formidable tous les producteurs bien sûr
de toutes les émissions
voilà qui ont travaillé avec moi cette
année julie raynaud bien sûr flory
valentin jeu en oubliez donc mais assure
yannick à courbessac à mon cap ou bep
qui est exceptionnel il ya mon ordi
aouicha qui étaient là aussi pendant
qu'on filme en cas combes est quelqu'un
d'exceptionnel pendant le confinement et
bien sûr il ya mon agatha d'amour qui
fait avec moi à prendre ou à laisser a
bien un qui est exceptionnel voilà je
vous dis loïc il ya deux cas tombe bien
voilà tous à fabien delhaye tremont
fabien de l'efs
voilà cédric 6r tous ceux qui
travaillent voilà au 6e rang donc merci
à eux
voilà je vous dis c'est pas pu citer
tout le monde
mais sachez que on a fait une année
magnifique grâce à vous voilà je voulais
vous le dirai donc l'année prochaine
c'est place à la d'arcade